[Música]
detuvieron en Argentina a un hombre que
intentó atentar contra la vicepresidenta
Cristina Fernández de kirchner en video
quedó registrado el momento en el que el
sujeto intentó accionar un arma a quema
ropa frente a la cara de la líder en la
puerta de su residencia
organizaciones de Derechos Humanos
denunciaron el que el gobierno de
Nicaragua está exhibiendo a sus presos
políticos en un mensaje amenazante a la
oposición 27 detenidos hace más de un
año fueron vistos en audiencias
judiciales con señales de desnutrición
el presidente de Estados Unidos yo
bailén pronunció su discurso contra lo
que llamó extremismo republicano sus
declaraciones se dieron de Cara a las
elecciones de medio término en noviembre
Hola y bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en francés 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Argentina el presidente Alberto
Fernández calificó El presunto ataque
contra la vicepresidenta Cristina
Fernández de kirchner como el hecho más
grave que ha vivido el país desde su
regreso a la democracia en video quedó
registrado el momento en el que la
también ex presidenta de Argentina fue
apuntada con un arma por un hombre que
se encontraba entre la multitud el
sujeto que ya fue detenido accionó la
pistola cargada Pero según el presidente
no se ha comprobado Cuál fue la razón
por la que la bala no salió esto Dijo el
mandatario
me he comunicado con la jueza que está
investigando lo ocurrido le he
solicitado que esclarezca rápidamente
las responsabilidades y los hechos
también le he solicitado que asegure la
vida del acusado que hoy se encuentra
detenido
Por ese motivo he dispuesto a declarar
en el día de mañana feriado nacional
para que en paz y armonía el pueblo
argentino pueda expresarse en defensa de
la vida de la democracia y en
Solidaridad con nuestra vicepresidenta
27 presos políticos nicaragüenses fueron
vistos en audiencias públicas de esa
semana de Managua sus familiares
denunciaron Que padecen desnutrición y
adelgazamiento extremo mientras que
organizaciones de Derechos Humanos
denunciaron que el gobierno de Daniel
Ortega los exhibió como mensaje
amenazante a la oposición en el país los
presos buscan con recursos de apelación
que las penas de traición o lavado de
dinero de las que se les acusa sean
conmutadas Andrés granadillo nos cuenta
más
reacciones en contra del gobierno de
Daniel Ortega tras conocerse las
imágenes de unos 10 opositores
condenados en Nicaragua el centro
nicaragüense de Derechos Humanos dijo
que varios presos políticos fueron
exhibidos en un desfile macabro como un
mensaje de amenaza a los opositores su
deterioro es visible según sus familias
el periódico oficialista del digital
dijo que los detenidos asistieron a una
audiencia en la capital donde los jueces
les informaron sobre sus recursos de
apelación nuevas audiencias contra
presos golpistas terroristas y traidores
de la patria entre los condenados están
los ex aspirantes presidenciales Juan
Sebastián Chamorro merardo mairena y
Miguel Mora Quienes fueron arrestados
antes de los comicios de noviembre de
2021 en esas elecciones Ortega resultó
elegido para un cuarto mandato
consecutivo en medio de cuestionamientos
Internacionales también fue citado
audiencia El dirigente estudiantil
Lester alemán uno de los líderes de las
protestas contra el gobierno de Ortega
en 2018 detenido el año pasado
organizaciones como amnistía
internacional denunciaron las
violaciones de Derechos Humanos a las
que están sometidos los presos políticos
y un pueblo que está sometido al
sufrimiento de ver a las personas
detenidas arbitrariamente por motivos
políticos en condiciones de deterioro
constante en donde el maltrato y que
pudiese constituir tortura es parte de
esta política de represión otras ong
también dicen que los 27 presos
políticos opositores detenidos en la
cárcel policial el chipote están
irreconocibles y con evidentes problemas
de salud enfrentan penas entre 7 y 13
años de cárcel por delitos considerados
como traición a la patria o lavado de
dinero
Santiago de Chile fue escenario de
nuevas protestas de estudiantes los
enfrentamientos con la policía
coincidieron con los eventos del cierre
de campaña a favor y en contra de la
nueva constitución chilena que será
votada este domingo en un plebiscito el
futuro del texto sigue siendo incierto
debido a una recia oposición de algunos
sectores de la sociedad
la universidad de Santiago entrega
gratuitamente 400 ejemplares de la nueva
propuesta de Constitución la campaña por
el plebiscito en chile se ha centrado en
que se conozca y se debata el texto
constitucional para que todos los
chilenos voten teniendo conocimiento del
documento Jordania agradece hacerse con
una copia Oficialmente
de una manera informada Me parece muy
importante informarnos para votar
informado y tomar una muy buena decisión
con respecto a lo que al futuro del país
algunos chilenos desestiman
constituciones falsas que se han
distribuido durante la campaña y luchan
contra la desinformación
es decir cierta o falsa pero aquí mismo
tenemos una copia original entonces para
informarnos por nuestros propios medios
la mayoría de las encuestas dan como
favorito al rechazo desde hace meses Los
partidarios de esta tendencia reunidos
aquí al caer la tarde apuestan porque no
se apruebe el texto constitucional por
calificarlo como divisorio la propuesta
la rueda puesto que divide el país
dificulta el manejo del país
[Música]
en estos días es habitual encontrar en
Chile lugares donde se lee la
Constitución Los partidarios de la
prueba creen que el texto Habla por sí
solo parte de la familia de Nancy de 72
años Fue ejecutada en dictadura ahora
Espera que esta nueva constitución que
contiene artículos explícitos sobre la
prohibición de desapariciones forzosas y
respeto a los Derechos Humanos cambie
esta situación para siempre en el país
por lo que ya no están y también por
nosotros aprovechemos
[Aplausos]
muy muy justo que esté escrito algo que
quede absolutamente explícito a los
derechos de los disidentes
ideológicos en la carrera del plebiscito
el rechazo parte como Favorito pero las
encuestas se han equivocado antes en
chile y la gran incertidumbre es Cuántas
personas participarán en la primera
elección con voto obligatorio desde 2012
y hacia grande se inclinará su voto
Aún es de las elecciones generales en
Brasil las autoridades se apresuran a
crear más mecanismos de control para
hacer frente a las noticias falsas que
durante la anterior Campaña en 2018
fueron según los expertos muy relevantes
para la victoria de Jair
la desinformación vuelve a entrar en
Campaña en Brasil a un mes de las
elecciones generales minimizar las
noticias falsas sigue siendo uno de los
objetivos elementales para las
autoridades que aunque están hoy mucho
mejor preparadas que en 2018 todavía
deben controlar millones de contenidos
que inundan sin filtros las nuevas
plataformas sociales
ha habido cambios para combatir la
desinformación en estas elecciones
respecto a las anteriores la justicia
electoral ha creado por ejemplo una
comisión de seguimiento permanente para
evitar la difusión de información falsa
con un grupo compuesto a día de hoy por
más de 100 profesionales de las más
diversas áreas
Hace cuatro años los comicios estuvieron
empañados por la difusión masiva de fake
news especialmente por WhatsApp según
expertos aquello tuvo un impacto
importante en la victoria del
ultraderechista Yair bolsonaro ahora se
buscan a contrarreloj más mecanismos de
control es
que la justicia electoral defina un
procedimiento simplificado para recibir
las denuncias evaluarlas retirar el
contenido engañoso de los medios de
comunicación y sancionar rigurosamente a
los responsables
desde el Tribunal Superior electoral ya
se ha ordenado la eliminación de varias
decenas de contenidos la mayoría de la
campaña del actual mandatario una
cuestión todavía preocupante
[Música]
desde las últimas elecciones que fue
cuando ganó bolsonaro el tema de las
fake news se ha hecho mucho más fuerte
precisamente por la campaña de nuestro
actual presidente y es muy preocupante
de verdad porque creo que mucha gente lo
eligió con base en varias fake news
varias informaciones sesgadas que él
mismo transmitió a la población
por el momento plataformas como WhatsApp
han restringido la creación de grupos
hasta después de los comicios más
polarizados en décadas en los que el
expresidente Lula da Silva continúa
aventajado en la contienda cerca de 15
puntos porcentuales el presidente de
Estados Unidos Joe biden pronunció un
discurso en el que advirtió que la
igualdad y la democracia están bajo
ataques refiriéndose a los republicanos
cobijados por el liderazgo de su
predecesor Donald Trump y a sus
seguidores entre la ciudadanía civil
esto a dos meses de las elecciones de
medio término de noviembre
los republicanos del make América Great
Again no respetan la Constitución no
creen en el estado de derecho no
reconocen la voluntad del pueblo se
niegan a aceptar los resultados de unas
elecciones libres las fuerzas de Maga
están decididas a hacer retroceder este
país retroceder a una nación donde no
hay derecho a elegir ni derecho a la
privacidad ni derecho a la
anticoncepción y derecho a casarse con
quien amas promueven líderes
autoritarios y las llamas de la
violencia política que son una amenaza a
nuestros derechos personales a la
búsqueda de la justicia al Estado de
derecho al alma misma de este país
hasta que este informativo Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]